[MUSIC PLAYING]
DYANN F. WIRTH: Malaria
is a complex organism.
It's a eukaryotic pathogen.
It has over 5,000 genes.
It exists in the insect vector.
And in the human host, it exists
in the liver and in the red cell.
Malaria eradication means eliminating
an organism from the face of the Earth.
And to do that, we need to understand
the biology of the organism
in order to develop the
necessary tools, drugs, vaccines,
and other interventions.
In addition, the parasite's ability
to adapt to external challenges,
to drugs, to the human immune
system, to the mosquito vector
make it a fascinating biological system.
KENT KESTER: Parasites have
evolved with us for millennia.
They know how to hide out.
They know how to live with us.
DYANN F. WIRTH: The course brings
together people from malaria control
programs, from
nongovernmental organizations,
from academic institutions
to work together
to develop the skills that are
needed to lead this effort.
[MUSIC PLAYING]